hopes for a return to democracy in
Guinea fading two years after a military
coup
and there's no tolerance for those who
want to express their frustration
the coup in September 2021 ousted
president Alpha Conde he'd won a
contested election after changing the
Constitution so he could run for a third
term
as included supported not the coup but
the fact that we ended an unconstitution
of that term then they promised to put
Guinea back on track with a
constitutional Charter we asked for an
inclusive dialogue but today nothing is
being done the government has no
intention of holding elections we have
the necessary equipment and an electoral
role they are making excuses to avoid
elections the military government says
there will be Democratic elections but
they've not given any roadmap protesting
getting against the transitional
government are often violently
suppressed another reason why opposition
groups don't believe the government is
sincere when it says it's committed to a
democratic transition
the only officially sanctioned event was
a concert it was sparsely attended
giant posters of the man who led the
coup Colonel mamani dumbaya loomed over
the crowd
now he's president he didn't turn up nor
did any of his ministers
we're here in support of dumb Boya
because he supports us he should not
Retreat or be scared we are his
supporters and we are with him
we are here to celebrate with Canon
nombuya this is an important celebration
for all of those who are in support of
the president
for an interview
you didn't have any
have any diary
two years into the third coup guineas
had since Independence all the
government can offer in place of a
return to democracy is a reminder that
it still has military force behind it
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera conocry Guinea
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera